people are asking a question saying pat
did you really move to florida
all right and if you've done it because
i wrote a letter years ago saying dear
california
i'm leaving you it's a love letter so
it's a lovely letter
i should check that out it's a breakup
letter breakup letter i wrote to
california breakdown
yes but and she still calls she's still
right she still pursues you still
we still have a guy i miss you baby yes
we still have a conversation you go
you visit you slide in you say what's up
and then you're out
late night text yeah so but uh
but uh texas is not really a breakup
texas is like
we're moving because texas and florida
have a lot in common but i wanted to
find out
what florida does with taxes because
texas they said oh you go to texas
let me tell you the property taxes are
really high guess what they are hired in
california there's no question about it
if you want a house in california
versus texas property taxes are much
higher
than it is in california but florida is
not
necessarily higher uh of property taxes
than texas so how do they make their
money how does florida make their money
did you know florida gets 140 million
tourists every year
2019. forget about 2020 obviously things
change but prior to that it's 140 per
year
yep you got disney world you got the
universal studios you got miami you got
so many different
beach you got south beach you got the
best libraries in south beach it's a lot
of
different libraries best libraries right
many reasons why people come to florida
right
for the library did you know florida has
a seven percent sales tax
but florida has a five percent tourist
tax
hmm they call it the florida tourist tax
which means if you're a tourist and you
come here
whatever you do if you live and they
define tourists as less than six months
right if you live here less than six
months you pay that additional five
percent
so that additional five percent they tax
tourists
and they allow the folks who live here
to not pay taxes so they collect taxes
from sales
they collect taxes from citizens from
tourists but they don't collect taxes
state taxes
from folks who live here think about
that yeah what a way to
you it's not necessarily punishing
you're taxing those
who want to come here for vacation
you're coming here but if you're living
here they're like look no state taxes
will get the money from somewhere else
great brilliant idea if you ever want to
run a country something to be thinking
about yeah i'm thinking about running
um free belts for everybody this is
what's going on here
with all the talk about the trillions
and trillions of dollars the government
spending in
the federal deficit the budget for for
florida is 90.98 billion dollars
pretty interesting 90.98 billion dollars
to run
and the general general revenue portion
is 33.93
billion per governor ron desantis and
and i think they're the number four
state when it comes down to uh uh gdp
i think number one number two obviously
california new york you got california
new york texas
it's i think texas is actually number
two and then you got florida
so it is one of the top four that you're
looking at okay what they're doing so
but back to the your i have one question
yeah because i'm familiar with that
obviously the tourist tax and and all
that but where does that five percent
come from taxing the tourists where does
that come through sales
sales tax if you're staying at a hotel
you should show your id okay
it's okay the money's going to come from
summer obviously you're going to the
market publix doesn't say oh we're going
to pay five percent because you're not
from here
but they're collecting it from somewhere
and i think it's a brilliant idea
it's it's something that california and
others can learn from for sure
if you think about it california also
gets a lot of what
tourists are a lot of tourists i mean
you've got so much texas though
not as much as california before saying
that i'm starting my friends
in texas hey nobody wakes up and says i
need to go to san antonio
how many people you know who grew up in
south beach partied in south beach
have your reputation in south beach yeah
bodega all these other stuff that they
have shout out to
how many people you know yeah that went
and lived in addison for a year after
doing oh just one baby there's one guy
there's one guy
probably and his heart guy i love you i
left my heart
madison the guest shout out to texas
they get transplants
yeah they're so okay so but the point is
if you really think about what if they
said
what if california's the tourist taxes
10 percent were people paid what if they
said tourists taxes
they would still go they would still pay
you yes yes because they want to visit
no one can
you're going on vacation actually think
about this idea what if california ran
a tourist tax of 20 percent i so so
let's just say california wants to
compete
right people are like oh pat wants
california what if california
decided to compete with other states and
said hey new governor runs in the state
of california
okay yeah if a guy is listening to this
or if you know somebody that's running
for governor send this part to them let
them think about it and
if you hear it you know where you heard
it first what if the governor of
california says hey
right now state taxes are 133 right
go through the whole state taxes that we
cause you know biden we're going to get
into biden's tax plan he just announced
that he's raising the taxes
you know highest tax hike since 1993 the
new economic tax
you know he's gonna we'll talk matter of
fact we'll get into it right after right
off the bat
what if a governor in california says we
got a 13.3 taxes right now
but we got uh marty can you find out how
many tourists go to california in 2019
can somebody find out what that number
is what's interesting here too as well
is that
the state of florida had a 3.8 billion
in reserves
before the pandemic pandemic brought a
2.7 billion
deficit so they had more than enough to
deal with the
the coronavirus check this out that's uh
that's not the number mario there's a
number here that says
california expected to see 279
torrid 279 million tourists in 2019.
florida's 140 california is 2x that 280.
insane
right think about tourism yeah so if you
got 280 million people that go to
california for tours what if you say
moving forward we eliminate state taxes
in california 133 is gone however any
tourists come in here
20 taxes so if a room rate at the hotel
is 500 bucks guess what you're paying
600 bucks
if you're going in you know you're
you're you're getting in you know
an uber and uber says you're registered
in a different state but you get in
california it's a 20
right no it's a 24 right what if that 20
you know how europe has that vat you
know fat tax
okay it's like it's a consumption tax
what if they offered that 20
tax to taurus what how what do you think
that number would drop
go 280 and actually think about it i
want you to actually think about it man
both of you guys say california
announced officially 2023.
any tourist that comes to the state of
california taxes
are 20 for you for tourists anyone that
lives here for less than six months
how much you think that 280 million
tourists will drop from what it's going
to be a drop but what do you think that
drop is
yeah i mean 20 percent is aggressive i
mean even if it were 10 i want to be
aggressive okay guys i want to be
aggressive and say 20 percent i don't
think much at all what do you think that
280 million drops
10 percent 20 that's nothing yeah that's
nothing i don't think people are like i
could go on vacation let's say 20.
i would call it the 20-20-20 plan you
know what the 2020 plan is
we're gonna charge 20 for tourists and
we're going to lose 20 percent
of the 280 million coming it's okay that
is going to generate revenue and guess
what that's going to do if i eliminate
state taxes
now we're recruiting everybody back
think about what that could mean
but for that to be taking place you know
it's
it's a little scary for some of the
government officials working there is
pretty dramatic of an idea
but if you did something like that and
tourists are still gonna go to l.a
they're still gonna go to see the
hollywood
because what is the average travel if
you travel somewhere how much money do
we spend
say a husband and wife uh two kids
couple grand easy if you're gonna go to
california from uk
okay you're gonna spend what ten
thousand dollars for just
exactly with airfare and everything food
and the whole thing okay yeah let's just
say it's gonna be twelve thousand
dollars is that going to change your
mind of going away twelve thousand
instead of ten thousand dollars
from uk i'm just calculating flights and
everything yeah what if it's twelve
thousand dollars
still going still going do you think the
person's gonna say oh because of twelve
thousand dollars we're not going i don't
think so
i think they would still make the money
and i think california ought to really
consider this
forget about five percent go to 20
percent and eliminate that 13-3
anyways i woke up this morning guys in
california you know you guys keep
thinking like i'm hating on california
there's an idea for you go pitch it to a
potential future governor
or you go run in the state of california
as a governor and eliminate that state
taxes
it will be very very hard to compete
with the state of california
because if they eliminate the state
taxes 13-3
so the 20 you lose here on the tourists
you
gain and business owners move into you
forget about losing the tourists
you get jobs created you get people
saying why the hell would i go anywhere
then you have to put a limit on who can
come to the state of california
you got all the resources but
unfortunately
politics gets in the way for something
like this to take place this is why i'm
nominating adam to run
for governor in the state of california
and i'm your campaign manager yes thank
you
with you by my side i think we can win
this
for everyone no belt for you exactly so
you're basically saying florida uh
california take a page out of florida's
playbook do something
difficult but do something different and
double down instead of seven percent
five percent
go all in twenty percent screw it let's
do it you you can
by the way if you're listening to this
how many guys say
it's an interesting idea i like it put
thumbs up if you think right now we have
130 thumbs up
one thumbs down if you think it's a good
idea put thumbs up if you think it's a
terrible idea put thumbs up i'm curious
and then explain
why you think it's a terrible idea and
you would not entertain it
yeah because don't come to california so
you have two choices
okay you if you if you're governor of a
state
california which one do you prefer
tourists or small businesses coming to
you
small business is coming today so who do
you want to please more
who do you want to please more the job
creators your people the people that
want you to
you know dude that are there hey you're
paying 20
you are paying 20 tourists you want to
come visit us this is like it's my house
you want to come visit come on down it's
all good but you're a visitor
but i want to make sure the people that
live in that house are protected
i want to make sure those guys have the
biggest upside i want to make sure
people want to come
create for my economy right i i think
that's uh
i would be very this is one of those
videos that if we put this on vitamin
short clips
i want to hear commentary and i want to
hear you tear up my idea
just destroy the idea i want to read
every single article i'm going to
every single respond and i'm going to
comment to every one of those that gives
their explanation in the short clips
when it comes out i want to hear your
argument to say that's a terrible idea
what do you think the blowback is in the
bureaucracy in terms of politics why
would they push back on something like
that
what would they say what would these
special interests say why would not that
be
well if it so here's so this is what
it's going to come down to if you really
think about it like yesterday
i spoke to the former uh uh uh
this guy said the den of nerds live ten
bucks incredible idea could save the
state okay
uh so yesterday i uh i was speaking with
jimmy petronas jimmy patroness
is the cfo the state of florida he
follows valuetainment he unders you know
he knows the content and we're trying to
figure something out because you know
we'd like to have him we'd like to have
a governor desantis on to talk about
why what florida does and what part of
it is transferable to other states
so you ask the question what would
prevent the politicians to want to do
that sure right okay
well for me it works like this
say i'm sitting with my board and the
board comes up and says
you know the sales leaders come up and
say hey pat what about if we do such and
such id on the comp
okay what's the first thing i say first
thing we do is
let's run the data and see what it looks
like let's run some
you know beta tests and see what it
would look like let's go back six months
okay and we run it okay we run it what
would have changed
like we you know we're up we're up 160
for the month like this is a
record-breaking
these guys are not 160 percent they're
200 something plus percent
on what these guys are doing money smart
movement they're they're
they're gonna be five to ten million
dollar earners in no time the way
they're going i mean it's not even funny
yeah so so but imagine
the i go to the board i say guys i think
we need to do x y z
what are you talking about yes but then
i show the chart
and i say boom boom boom if you did this
you did this oh this you would do this
if they ran numbers and presented it
with the data
to say here's how much money you pulled
in from your 13.3 percent
here's your 279 million these 279
million go to disney world we can
collect the 20
tax from their disney's not paying for
the people that are going there are
paying for it so
if disney's tickets are 300 a pop all
they have to pay is what
360 that's an additional 20 you have to
pay for it you come in here nobody told
you to come you have disneyland disney
world pick one of the two
and at the same time
all of these florida nevada texas all
tennessee
all of these places that are recruiting
our small business owners away
we shut those people up and they stay
put and not only that
guess what we do now you get on the hall
you get on the radio you get on the
video you play offense and you say hey
if you left us guess what hey
hey if you did this now you're
presenting now this doesn't mean people
are going to move back because
if you're already in the state of texas
you're paying zero percent state taxes
or florida you're not really going to
move back like listen yeah i hope you
realize i'm moving my dad here i moved
my sis this is not a message i wanted to
move back to california
zero if we can turn off our ringtone
someone's ringtone is going off
if we can turn it off so mario it's is
it yours or just tell your girl your
caller back afterwards
jesus mario and his girlfriend tell her
relax
dude one or like mary please that's
enough
mary there's marriage we've told mary
leave it alone from 8 30 to 10 30.
but um i heard his aisha
you know you remind me of what what if
what if macarena and i said she says i
have no idea
you were saying something i was just
saying is this something that you just
magically woke up and
i got an idea or have you been
ruminating about this for a little while
24 hours i've been thinking about it all
day from you last night i was telling
you guys about it at midnight i'm like
what a brilliant california is one move
away
one move away if the right governor goes
there
who knows how to sell this because this
has to be sold
right this cannot be like i think we can
have a great idea if we
charge tourists 20 like you can't say is
that wrong
who is that whoever it is like the
boring politicians cannot sell this idea
it has to be somebody that can sell this
is a ridiculous revolutionary idea that
could save the state
yeah it's that big of an idea but um
hopefully someone like chamath who's
running for i believe governor
sees something like this and it ends up
on his radar and
i think the point that you're making is
california needs to shake things up
the status quo people are moving they're
getting the hell out of there they're
recalling governor
gavin newsom you know it's just not a
tax friendly state they need to do
something different
and take a playbook out of florida or
who knows will california be the number
one state in the country moving forward
yeah no i i i think it's such a
revolutionary idea but if the math
backs up my argument it's game over yeah
if math backs up the argument it's game
over your dad would be the driver
let's get some magnification it would be
game
over you know who would follow us to
write afterwards guess who would do new
york
new illinois you would have all those
three states do it
okay because all those three states have
a lot of what
tourists yep all those three states
what's can we find out what
whose is that it's on the ipad it's
something it's a mac max something
that's making that kind of a noise
who is who's is that is that yours no
it's not okay
i'm on silent mode so i'm curious now to
find out what's
new york's uh 2019
tourism everybody guys everybody check
it out as if it's
illinois you do illinois do tour new
york
uh 2019
new york taurus new york state tourism
statistic 2019.
what do we have 265 and a half million
and it was 280 in california so new york
and california second
thing they could do the same thing
generating an economic impact of 118
billion dollars
illinois 120 million wow 120 million
florida's one florida
yeah yeah but yeah but but still
surprised chicago that's the weather
that's ridiculous so so you gotta you
got 280 million california you got 265
and a half million
new york you got 140 florida you got 120
in new york
buddy i mean this this could it's a
playbook that could be used
you want by the way you know who
wouldn't like this
who wouldn't like this china wouldn't
like this because they're getting wet
taxes coming in china wouldn't like this
it would actually unify the country
it would unify the country because
you're putting everybody
like actually be the devil's advocate
give me the argument like what part of
it you're like well it's not going to
work here well what if this argument
what would you say to it
i mean coming in they have choices
countries let alone states
you know they were paying a little bit
more of a premium i would
think that would also happen to the
small businesses too as well so not only
the individuals
but i would also say that for lack of a
better term whatever tariffs or income
taxes or states
uh sales taxes have to come through the
uh chinese tourism
would come in and being say you know
what we got you know england to go to
australia to go to whomever it would be
you know
pinging that off the different you know
ideas of where to go to but what's the
devil like what would be yeah
i'm trying to come up with the devil's
advocate like for instance i don't know
many people that say well i was gonna go
to florida i was gonna go to disney
world
but that five percent tax i can't i
don't never heard it
so you know the more we're going down
this path
essentially what you're saying is help
the small businesses
help states recruit more businesses
and have the freaking tourists pay the
tax the one thing that i guess
the devil's advocate we're thinking
international tourism
that's what we're thinking international
tourism sure but
you know state to state tourism i guess
is where it
gets a little slippery because you know
you're taxing your fellow citizens if
you're talking about nationalism and
you know bringing everybody together and
coalescing
you're still going to be taxing fellow
americans no visiting yourself yeah yeah
but guess what what i'm trying to tell
you is i love my state
gotcha you're going straight i'm
protecting
my constituents that's your job when you
get elected
touche as the governor yeah as the
governor i'm your advisor i'm advising
you as a future governor
correct you're i'm your i'm your uh you
know your
advisor your job is to protect them who
wouldn't like it in the state of florida
this
you're going to get pushback from who
disney mm-hmm
universal studios some of the people
some of the tourist businesses in south
florida may not agree with that they're
going to be like hey you're
kind of keys may say you're hurting us
right but a lot of people that go
through
this why would the businesses in florida
oppose this why wouldn't they this is
gonna
be saying oppose other states doing it
uh no no florida would oppose if you
raise the tourist tax to 20 percent
disney would oppose it universal studios
would oppose it
so any anybody that realized like when
you go to croatia they get four million
tourists every year
this small island called dubrovnik yeah
beautiful island beautiful
yeah the only revenue is
tourism right we were in hawaii how many
times did people say thank you
thank you thank you for opening us up
you know the photographers the
taxis the restaurants people think you
were hawaiian by the way they'd say
what's up uso
but the but the point is hawaii same
thing they rely on tourism yeah okay so
who would oppose it those small
businesses who rely on tourism
but would they benefit long term from
small business owners moving there
someone's going to take a hit no matter
what the hit's going to be put on the
tourist
it's going to be put on the tourist
business locally
but long term that state's going to get
a lot of benefits of people staying
there and commerce and business not
leaving i can't believe we spent 20
minutes talking about
yeah california taxes allow me to just
give one sort of epiphany that i had
since doing this podcast
one thing you made me full on understand
is that governors
need to be recruiters to their state
there's no question but you can't just
sit back or run our states
your job is to bring in jobs to bring in
talent um or you're gonna fall by the
wayside and that's something that i
think florida's doing a good job of
obviously
you got recruited by rick perry come on
down to it
stranger's game i couldn't believe how
good it was he can't name the three
different uh
uh parts of uh economy that he'd like to
change but he could recruit your ass out
of california
so and right now if you look at the guy
that's the leading candidate to be the
president
2024 don't say behind trump don't say it
behind
trump don't say it behind are you about
to say desantis the santis
is the leading candidate according to
cpac
not according to cpac according to data
more than pence
blm trusted florida more than any other
state
nba trusted florida well they're the
only state that was open
but that's why you come in here then
shut down the nba
the nba needs to thank the santis
because you chose to do your nba
playoffs in florida and the super bowl
and the super bowl at the end of the
olympics
he his policies has
garnered him the conversation of being
considered 20 24 candidates yes
for presidency they're also i mean look
i i i'm no he gets hate no no
guilty is charged florida's getting a
lot of hate right now during spring
break like it's
a full-on zoo going on in fort
lauderdale partied hardcore thursday
friday
saturday sunday and you decided to make
wednesday ladies ladies
let me tell you something i'm at the
point where i can go hard one night
friday night i'm done for the rest of
the week i usually go friday saturday
running back on sunday i'm at the point
where it's like i'll go hard on a friday
stories disappears in 24 hours yeah you
know you're very fortunate yeah if you
see adam not posting ig stories for two
days he's been part of that yeah yeah
zero guilty i think ron desantis
needs a nickname what i mean rhonda
like ron like instead of run dmc like
the magnet desantis i think it's like a
magnet attraction what about
florida what about like ron gdp instead
of uh
the cmc ron gdp ron
d okay okay i'm going sorry it says
something
coming from illinois yeah both going to
texas and florida has been a completely
different world for me coming from
illinois yeah
when when when i got coveted right away
i found a 15-minute
rapid test all within uh five 10-mile
radius found three of them
in illinois it's it's a doctor's
appointment and then it's so you're
saying you were found
you're saying you were in texas
in texas but right away i think i think
a lot of us did
i think we're all in texas is guilty for
that and then coming to florida
you know the the the businesses are open
people are inside the restaurants i'm
actually shocked by the way chicago i
know it's 33 and snowing out there right
now
it's 80 and balmy out here in florida
look at recruiting recruiters see
it's easy to constantly recruit great
recruiters 15th move 15th move
but five years he'll be here yeah we're
making 10 million dollars a year i'll be
buying a house in your neighborhood
at that point we'll be making some
exciting announcements here very soon we
may make something excellent oh really
no no no not really no not him but but
but even you're pregnant again
even what he said he said with other
things he said uh
uh vps yeah he said uh the fact that you
know
covet all that stuff and within 15
minutes he finds three places to go do
it
i call my guys in california i call
ricky i said ricky
go get tested ricky had to drive from
bakersfield
to glendale to get tested right on two
hour drive what is that
it's not even with from bakersfield to
glendale there's there's a bunch of
cities you go through
that are good-sized cities none of them
you mean to tell me none of them have
how's that even
how's that freaking possible right but
it's like a third world country
because you've only lived your plus
you've lived in other places
but your experiences are in states ran
by
abbot and desantis yeah so for you your
leaders have been desantis and abbott
that's all you know you don't know
newsom
like i don't know something like that no
i don't know
like some people have hated well you've
never learned in california and you've
got to live in california well news is
doing a great job and obviously our good
friend
uh uh andrew cuomo is doing a great job
people are very excited about him these
days
i say we have a camera follow you yeah
and you go to live in california for one
year
okay and you tell us how you feel about
it yeah i'm sure my attitude would
change
about uh everything you think so i mean
a lot of people i feel like recruiting
you to be that governor because you go
there and all these policies are gonna
all of a sudden
that could work you know what sasnik
showed up the tax changed
percent tourism tax where you got it
from
yeah so tell us about uh the biggest
difference is the tourist
taxes that's the tourists it's a great
campaign taxi
tourist tv
in illinois in chicago right now i mean
you kind of brushed over it a little bit
but
i mean you've been in texas now you've
been in florida for a few days and you
spent some time in florida
biggest differences in your mind uh
politically socially economically what
have you seen well first of all illinois
we've got four governors has been to
prison that's number one
yeah uh it's it's a broad envelope type
of state for governors in
the past how long uh last 20 years
really there was a blah blah what was
his name
and then uh you know you got pretty much
chicago were they all democrat
or are there some republicans uh because
they're a republican no
so they so so equal opportunity uh
criminals and you pretty much have one
county one city
pretty much running the whole entire
state that's chicago
right cook county yeah yeah cook county
in chicago okay
exactly county chicago but you know
there's uh you know you've got uh
governor pritzker right now
who is uh who's with the 53 richest
uh man in the world family time of
course yep so he's running it he's a big
boy too
you know when he was when he was running
for governor we went to meet him first
question i asked him how did we fix the
pension plan
the pension programs and no real quick
answer there no real
plan uh i was very happy on election
night
if there's one thing to be happy on
election night was that he was
attempting to inc
to put a progressive income tax in
illinois not just a flat tax yeah and
they got voted out
uh he put 53 million dollars of his own
money to campaign for progressive income
tax his biggest donor to that whole
campaign
was fifteen hundred dollars so now a lot
of people believe in the progress
progressive and context and i'll know
but yeah there's a lot of you know
there's just a lot of uh
you know a lot of uh challenges there uh
locally um
and so that's the excitement uh you know
talking with a robert ishmael of
illinois policy institute so
you know there's a lot of things that
we're looking to get involved in so if
you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
you